grands sont gérard larcher détient en
partie les clés d'un accord est ce que
vous pensez qu'il peut bloquer cette
réforme ou qu'un accord est encore
possible je ne crois pas que ce soit
dans l'état d'esprit du président du
sénat de bloquer quelques réformes que
ce soit parce que je crois que au fond
il n'est pas aussi conservateur qu'on
pourrait le lire ici ou là en réalité la
réforme ce reportage est très utile
parce qu'on comprend mieux que tout
quand on parle de réformes
constitutionnelles il y a en effet
plusieurs niveaux et plusieurs plusieurs
degrés ce que je vais vous dire ce matin
c'est que la réforme institutionnelle
il s'agit pour nous de transformer la
démocratie de la moderniser c'est aussi
important que la transformation
économique ou que la transformation
sociale n'oublions pas les conditions
dans lesquelles nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir la défiance vis-à-vis de pouvoir
politique vis-à-vis des institutions
certes nous sommes arrivés au pouvoir
est d'ailleurs notre arrivée prouve
qu'il y avait déjà quelque chose qui ne
fonctionnait pas dans le système
politique mais nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir avec une abstention très très
forte et avec un vote populiste ou
extrémiste excessivement élevés
aujourd'hui nous voulons réviser le
fonctionnement de la démocratie parce
qu'il faut rétablir cette confiance
entre les citoyens et leurs classes
dirigeantes
c'est essentiel le président de la
république s'y engager à l'occasion de
sa campagne électorale c'était à
strasbourg il l'a redit au congrès au
mois de juillet dernier c'est un cap
qu'il nous a fixé et nous mènerons cette
réforme dans cette réforme il y a
évidemment des choses qui ont été déjà
annoncées qui était au coeur de notre
programme d pour rendre le parlement
plus efficace avec des parlementaires
moins nombreux avec un autre scrutin
rénové en désaccord avec l'interdiction
du cumul du mandat dans l'espace et dans
le temps il y a évidemment des points de
désaccord avec le sénat mais nous aurons
à aborder ces sujets ensemble vous
l'avez rappelé le président de l'otc des
points sur lesquels un compromis peut
être trouvé où il y aura de la ferme a
fait livrer par élémentaire à ce stade
est évidemment privilégié pourquoi parce
que française rugy a évidemment mis en
place des groupes de travail pour faire
des propositions gérard larcher a rendu
les siennes cette semaine et le
président de la république a un cap
aujourd'hui nous nous avons mandat pour
transformer la démocratie vous pensé
pour tenter d'obtenir ces trois
cinquièmes un texte institutionnel dont
nous allons fêter le 60ème anniversaire
au mois d'octobre
moi je n'ai pas de pronostic affaires
sur les résultats d'un congrès je dis
juste que nous avons dans ce domaine
comme dans les autres une obligation de
résultat et que dans ce domaine comme
dans les autres nous mèneront les
réformes pour lesquelles nous avons été
élus il ya plusieurs façons d'y arriver
là sont de résultats mais nicolas
n'oublie qu'il avait juste en tant qu'
en tant que parlementaire grand soin est
ce que ça ne vous pose pas de problème
qu'on passe au dessus du parlement ce
qui me poserait problème c'est qu'à
cause de conservatisme de gens qui
veulent préserver le système dans lequel
ils sont depuis tant et tant d'années
certains qui ont reçu un mandat des
français ne puissent pas aller au bout
de leur démarche nous nous avons eu un
mandat des français pour transformer la
france elle voudra de relance former le
système politique
si nous ne pouvons pas il mener ces
réformes ils attisent lorsqu'il y aurait
des conservatismes de part et d'autre en
tout cas qui nous permettraient pas
d'atteindre les 3 6m tout précisément si
je ne sais pas on verrait qu'il voterait
ou pas la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires la fin du cumul des
mandats dans l'espace et dans le temps
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle nous voulons moderniser
la démocratie nous voulons que la
démocratie soit plus à l'image de la
société française de sa richesse de sa
diversité
aujourd'hui nous voulons ça c'est sûr et
nous le répéterons autant que faire se
peut nous voulons sortir d'un système de
carrière politique ou des professionnels
de la politique vont de mandat en mandat
et puis nous avons d'autres réformes à
faire faire en sorte que la démocratie
soit plus ouvert plus participative
c'est aussi la réforme du c'est ce qui a
été annoncé font ça ils précisément
cette semaine par le président de
république nous mènerons cette réforme à
son terme